Ron White's comedy salute to the Troops  starring Ron White we're gonna have a  party it's called Operation hangover  with special guest Kathleen Madigan I  spent two weeks in Afghanistan we got a  hundred and fifty Humvees here but  nobody could pick up a porta potti and  Lewis Black  they put a helmet on me they put a flak  jacket on they they handed me a rifle  and I fell right over and musical guests  Margo  ray John Oates and Rascal Flatts  Ron White's comedy salute to the Troops  with Tim Wilson Robert Hopkins dick  Henley and Alex Reymundo we have a  little french bulldog named pearl and  the other day my wife said I finally  figured it out that dog is jealous of me  that dog loves you so much he can't  stand it if I'm in the same way as you  and I said oh don't be ridiculous and  she walked into the kitchen and pearl  jumped on my stomach and said I can have  all your babies at the same time what  she's coming back like nothing's going  on nothing is going on  you